please give a warm welcome to Miran and
she's going to
hi everyone I'm midden or tiara first of
all thank you for coming thank you thank
you for inviting me
yeah actually it's the first second
being really enough yeah
so I am Rhydian I'm the product manager
of the Sun Samsung's new voices is in
big speak in German I'm very proudly say
our voice assistant speaks very German
than I do so yeah my in my tell first of
all I will talk a bit about this
paradigm shift that we are experiencing
with new technologies coming never
nonstop on the my path then I will from
our linguist I'm a linguist so from a
linguist perspective I will tell you
what actually is voicing direction how
we talk how we speak and so on spot and
then I will pre flee talk about the
technologies that in we that we use in
natural language processing to achieve
that human communication so I know this
is a very new topic like voice voice
assistance oh my god they are spying in
my living room or something like that a
lot of people are very reluctant and I
understand why but technology is
constantly evolving and we are
introducing it in our lives without
hardly noticing and when we look back
sometimes we don't even remember how it
was before it was before the
technologies that we existed for example
now I'm going to present you two
pictures that were taken in the same
street eight years apart in a very
similar event ok so this picture was
taken in va la cancion in Rome when john
paul ii died and you see everyone
learning the Pope or the Pope has died
that idea and the next picture was taken
exactly in the same street 8 years apart
when Pope Francis was elected see if you
notice the difference
so technology is creeping us it's
creeping into our lives and it doesn't
have to be bad it's just a way it's just
we are just generating new tools to
communicate or experience the world
better or to access the world's
information better and that's Indiana at
the end of the day that's exactly what
voice assistants do they give us access
to information in the world in a faster
and more natural way so but one thing I
have learned in my dream my career in
academia or in industry or in research
centers is that no matter how much you
know about linguists and other languages
no matter how good of a linguist you are
no linguist in the world knows how we
talk how we speak how we learn languages
so how do we teach computers something
that we don't understand fully ourselves
and that's the biggest challenge but we
can all agree that the following steps
is what makes human voice interaction
first of all we need to hear
Soundwave kind of then we have to
understand it which is not the same I
can listen to Chinese but I will not
understand a word then produce a
response to it and then utter it I
understand French very well and I can
even think about the response but I am
unable to speak it out for example and
if you look closely in my natural
language processing we have the exact
same counterparts and machines do these
steps in in a way so for hearing we have
automatic speech recognition for
understanding we have natural language
understanding which is which would be
extracting the meaning of the words of
the sentences then we have to prepare a
response so what the user has said and
then we the machine has to kind of utter
it out chatbots
usually give you the written response
but in a voice assistant is very
important that it has to be voice
experienced end to end so you had you
need a very good TTS
speech synthesiser so now we walked you
through the one of the so each of the
technologies from our perspective on
this so in a is on here the objective is
to teach the Machine how to transcribe
some wave into a written sentence and to
do that we have we encountered a huge
challenge first which is language
variability it's considered that is that
the human being does not utter the same
vowel twice in his life so we may think
no I just said a today two times no you
didn't because maybe it didn't have very
high frequency there was some glitch or
whatever so how should a machine just
happen to your image of what a vowel is
to this so we start by defining a
phonetic alphabet this is the German
phonetic alphabet that but then of
course if you define only different
German phonetic alphabet the system is
not going to be able to for example
understand happy birthday the day sound
doesn't exist in German so there is
always a big discussion when defining
day in the alphabet and then we also
feed a lot of transcribed audio core
pram basically
transcribed so audio corpora audio texts
that are transcribed phonetically so the
machine come up the sounds to the
phonemes but of course if we only feed
that to the machine and we learn from
that only we would have a long string of
phonemes so you remember when you were
children and I had struggles at least
that when I was learning to write I
didn't know when the words ended so I
wrote everything together so we have to
now teach the machine to cut the string
into words and to do that we feed them
we feed language models language models
in form of text corpora cut into engrams
so very briefly what is an Engram an
Engram is basically a string of words he
could be a to Graham a bigram a string
of
two words three Brom a string of three
words and so on and so forth and what we
do is we give a statistical value or a
statistical wave to each Engram so they
have and that tells us not only how
likely it is for a word to happen but
also how likely it is for a word to
happen we've given the previous word so
that way without giving any linguistic
information the machine knows that each
goes with hubba and not with hust
because it's more likely the
probabilities higher that ish goes with
haba so imagine that the Machine
transcribes phonetically the following
sentence maybe any fellow linguist know
such a such a string with a vowel in the
beginning and African and African in the
second place it could be
chances are it's the world ish but then
it's it's happen what is that I don't
know okay let's try happen but has a
very low probability so let's go with
Hubble oh yeah that has a bigger
probability so let's go with Hubble
so and so on and so forth we complete
the whole sentence and that is how very
like ASL works so now we have translated
transcribe the sound wave into a written
sentence but now we have to extract
meaning out of it a sentence just
written doesn't mean anything and here
is the word the big revolution has
happened like ten years ago fifteen
years ago everything was pasted into a
key word recognition it was yours okay
if you understand this key word then do
that but words even if they are listed
in dictionaries and you can check the
meaning of them words their meaning is
very very variable
it depends completely from the test from
the surrounding text from the context so
the big revolution now happening is that
we've gone from key word recognition to
intact intention recognition I will give
you an example so imagine we have
user that has a smart super smart home
and has a right home by the windows yeah
the Sun was shining and it's super super
hot at home so he says it's so hot in
here
and if we had a system that only
recognized key words and recognizes the
word hot say Oh hot hot let's make it
hot and turns the the heater on so
because here now hot that's hot alone
doesn't mean anything you need the whole
sentence to understand it so in
intentional recognition we analyze the
whole sentence and they we Anna
recognize that the customer or the user
is actually complaining that it's hot so
we turn the air conditioning on and to
do so in Bixby at least we work with
corpora in whole sentences so we do the
analysis of the whole sentence and we
mark the parameters and the machine so
the algorithm learns from the whole
structure it's not word based it's
sentence based is structure based syntax
is very very important in our in our
system so once it's well trained the
system will when you feed him a training
sentence it will create this kind of
trees that analyzes the data and the
parent and the parameters in it so now
we have our sentence
transcribed we extracted the meaning out
of it then we have to prepare a response
for natural language generation I have
to say our voice assistant and I I don't
think there is any in the market that is
productive we are not proactive
proactive means that the system talks to
you before you even address it so we
work with templates of sentences which
is not really natural language
generation natural language generation
like the real thing is a a poetry and so
on there is thus there is this kind of
things but we don't do that we think
it's annoying that you know every day
no this is the or a a poet or and yeah
poem of the day and yeah it would be
much so we just used like templates of
sentences and we changed slots in it
depending on the context so if we want
to turn the air conditioning on or off
we just change the verb so it would be
like slot filling and then once we have
the response ready we have to speak it
out we have to read it out and here
again the biggest problem is variability
yeah because as I said we always used
very very different sounds and if we
make it always sound the same it does
just doesn't sound natural so how do we
overcome it with the biggest corpus that
you can build so so you can get an idea
in these two sentences that I want in
the clarity form and one in
interrogative form it's an inside joke
for linguist but there is no linguist
sorry
there are in color for example the word
color you have this O's there but those
O's are very different from the oldest
uttered in the second sentences because
of the prosody of the sentence so based
that means basically that you need as
many samples of sound in different
places of the sentence surrounded by
different vowels consonants whatsoever
to make it sound natural for Bigsby we
built a corpora of 33,000 sentences that
were then taken to a recording studio
and a voice talent or an actor was was
chosen and she recorded the 33 K
sentences for she was there for six
months recording but the voice is very
good
so basically in the end one will have
the centers that we want to utter we
just what we build this big corpora we
recorded we chunk we split everything
into different sounds and when we have
to synthesize a sentence we just go okay
I need this constant I mean it's fowl
and so on and so forth
away and we build this sentence and then
another layer comes in in order to make
it sound smoother and we speak it out I
know there are a lot of initiatives now
to make it you can actually build a
synthesizer quite quite fast with the
way smaller corpus and but to make it
market ready to make it sound really
natural you need I mean the best
approach right now is just power just
feeding a lot of a lot of data so yeah
basically we put a lot of our corpus and
read it out so cool
everything is very cool very flashy but
what did you with what do you do with it
we are happy to announce that we already
developed
so we already launched the big speed
developers website here you can download
the IDE of big speed and you can build
capsules I mean something they are
called capsules always call them skills
it's the same okay so yeah you can build
a capsule for your company for your
whatever for yourself and yeah not still
you have to contact Samsung in order to
upload the capsule but hopefully soon
you can do it on your own and that is
everything thank you
oh yes questions yeah we have so many
questions
oh okay we can only take two or three so
we be charged
remember questions are not about
yourself first full of Makati law
collector where can we have developer
access to your fantastic speech
revelation to whet to the word developer
access to implement some cool stuff with
it here fantastic thank you thank you
and was short brief test test alright
thanks for the presentation my question
is so you focus on XP in german only not
only i mean we we are in charge of in
German but bigotry has been launched in
five languages exactly but I mean well
you you focus you personally focus on
Bixby in German primarily considering
there's big spear in many languages how
easy is it to shift features
intelligence from one language to
another or is it completely detached
systems okay welcome to the natural
language processing natural language
processing is developed her husband
developed for over decades by in the
u.s. in the u.s. so the core technology
actually is English however and his
token-based
which has implications later on he picks
P was not developed first for German it
was to develop first for English Chinese
in Korean and German came like one year
later or something like that
so for NLU or so for ASL you have to
build the databases from scratch for any
language for NAU we use
core technology it's a random forest
network that you know does everything
and it is quite translatable of course
you always have problems with compounds
compound words and so on so fun in
German or like Graham we in German will
have to use markup languages to to
identify the gender of the words and so
on and so forth so if to say if there is
if it's one could be as ten or as Esther
or whatever my German is not much other
yeah in German we do need help of other
technologies like markup languages that
in English you don't but the core
technology is actually the same yeah
thank you very much I think if you have
another question
Viren is around so she's happy to answer
questions during the barbecue